Russian installed authorities in
occupied parts of Ukraine have been
holding so-called referendums on joining
Russia polling has begun despite
worldwide condemnation and a warning
from the U.N chief that the results will
not be recognized
ballots are being collected in the
regions of Herson saporizia luhansk and
Donetsk an area making up about 15
percent of Ukrainian territory as voting
continuous Kiev says it has recaptured
more ground in its continuing
counter-offensive
now the Voting is expected to last
several days and results in the Region's
annexation by Moscow Ukraine and Western
Government say they will not recognize
the outcome
vote organizers in Donetsk making house
calls bringing the ballot boxes straight
to the people
amid the backdrop of War residents are
being asked to vote on joining the
Russian Federation
of course it's important we were
wondering when we would join Russia life
will be calmer
the so-called referendums are being held
over five days
Russian news outlets say most of the
voting will take place door to door
Kremlin installed leaders in the regions
have been preparing for months signing
up residence as Russian citizens
in luhansk some see the vote as a way
out of war and deprivation
I think the referendum will be for the
best
there will be water and electricity and
people will feel like they are on their
native land
but for those who fled to Ukrainian held
parts of zaparisia the votes are a sham
it's a violation of international law
it's a fake task to show that occupied
territories want to join the Russian
Federation
which is a total lie
once the so-called referendums are
completed Moscow could then claim that
its own territory is under attack with
weapons provided by the West
now let's cross to Kiev where I'm now
joined by Petro poroshenko he was
President of Ukraine from 2014 to 2019.
welcome to uh DW Mr poroshenko we know
you don't accept these so-called
referendums in Ukraine's East but what
do you say to those people in Donetsk
and luhansk who see this vote as a way
out of the war who just won their normal
lives back
well this is definitely not a referendum
there is no one single vote of the uh
any people because it's impossible to
organize referendum like that within 48
hours
experience of the Switzerland is
preparing for several months or years
second
I'm actually confident that the
Constitutional Court of Ukraine exactly
the same like we do under my presidency
in year 2014 about the Crimea this is
definitely any unconstitution
and point number three this is the
Russian trick how to legitimize their
presence of their troops and even more
to have an uh attack including the
possible nuclear weapons attack from the
territory which was grabbed by Putin on
this fake referend are you worried about
a nuclear attack How likely do you think
it is
look uh putil is a crazy maniac
he is absolutely unadequate
and he thinks that he has only one
instrument how to settle this situation
is a black male he using the security
blackmail when he attacked Ukraine he
using the energy blackmail and everybody
in Germany and in the world know what
does it mean he using the cold blackmail
hunger blackmail by blocking Ukrainian
port and now he using the nuclear
contamination blackmail with the uh
nuclear power plant and he using the
nuclear attack blackmail and with this
situation I just want to remind you that
this is blackmail was the uh situation
when Ukraine voluntarily gave up the
third biggest nuclear nuclear Arsenal in
the in the uh world and how we can react
only one possible thing
which you do not use the nuclear weapons
if the West
definitely confirm that that would be
severe answer on the attack
directly to Puja that would be Act of
the suicide of Putin and because Putin
afraid this scenario this is the only
way how we can stop it we should have
joined Declaration of the nuclear power
in the world that that would be quick
and decisive reaction on the attack we
in Ukraine don't afraid their nuclear
attack despite of the fact that if Putin
used the nuclear weapons attack the
first point would be key exactly when
I'm saying here seven months ago I am
staying here when Russian tanks was five
kilometers from this place and the
soldiers of my Battalion were on their
front line in their pain today we are
not afraid of them and this is not safe
so you have met Vladimir Putin when
while you were a president in how far do
you think he has changed
I have several recommendations based on
my experience for negotiation with Putin
first please don't be afraid of food
if you are weak putting go as far as we
together allow him to go
second don't trust Putin with this
negotiation never keep his world
and third
would you understand only the fourth
that's our strength and that's why the
strength of Ukrainian Army the unity of
ukrainians society and people and their
strong Coalition in the world supporting
Ukraine and unity definitely stop
putting where he is and that's why he
used now the mechanism of the
conscription Drive the mechanism of the
nuclear blackmail this is not safe
neither him no he's uh
now the Ukrainian government has asked
Germany for example repeatedly to send
more modern battle tanks but Chancellor
all of Schultz insists that such steps
must be agreed among allies and that no
other country was sending Western Battle
thanks to Ukraine do you understand that
position
first of all
I want to thank
the NATO and NATO member states for the
decisive role
you play uh supporting Ukrainian armed
for Ukrainian state to stop Putin
without that that would be almost
impossible Point number two that uh this
is the
initiative of our sister party the CDU
and um
a little bit disappointed that today the
German Parliament bundestag do not
support this initiative I really count
on that point number three
you should understand that the more
weapons the more ammunition you supply
the shorter would be the way to the
peace it not exist in any other way
Putin do not understand the way of
compromise or the time of Diplomat is
finishing and now the best Diplomat is
Ukrainian Armed Forces supported by
their uh aliens and with that situation
definitely we need German tanks in that
situation we need German ammunition we
very much thanks for the German
artillery and we do not need by the way
German soldiers please help us to save
you help us to save Europe help us to do
our common job that definitely it will
be our job in responsibility and giving
thanks to Ukraine given supporting the
Ukrainian Armed Forces you are not
helping Ukraine you invest in in your
own security
the former Ukrainian president Petro
poroshenko there thank you very much
it's a pleasure thank you
now let's go straight to our Russia
analyst concert in Eggert who joins us
from the Lithuanian Capital Vilnius now
constantly what is Russia's aim with
these so-called referendums
well our degree uh get with President
poroshenko it is to legitimize Russian
presence on these territories and very
probably Annex them and uh kind of
observance say that very possibly the
annexation date because no one doubts
about the so-called result of this
so-called referendums which are not
referendi at all
to to basically Annex these territories
by the 7th of October which is Putin's
birthday and which is Putin's 70th
birthday so in the Soviet tradition it's
very important to do something for such
an important date and I suppose we are
looking towards full-scale annexation
concert in egada Russia analyst thank
you